hey guys this is the Reuben report I'm
the newly installed Cuban ambassador to
the United States dave rubin and i have
two of my favorite guests with me kathy
labman and Andy Rhys Meyers we're not
gonna cover Cuba because it just
happened and I know everybody likes to
pretend that they know exactly
everything about everything all the time
but I needed a couple minutes to think
about it and that all will do so not a
minute I needed just five minutes I
don't even have five minutes this
morning to make it happen so we'll do
Cuba next week which the whole story a
little change by then but here we go you
should buy this new product I have the
cold pundit in a box it's really good
literally that's the direction we're
going pundits on the walls and toys r us
and they would make a lot we just sold I
didn't mean to interrupt the leo Abby
terrible sorry all right here we go so I
you guys probably heard about this Jeb
Bush has announced there's Jeb he has
announced that he is going to at least
form an exploratory committee to think
about the possibility of maybe
potentially running for president which
pretty much means he's running for
president here's the note that Jeb
posted on his Facebook page Merry
Christmas and Happy Hanukkah like many
of you our family was blessed with the
opportunity to gather together over the
recent thanksgiving holiday colombia and
I are so proud of the wonderful adults
our children have become and we love
spending time with our three precious
grandchildren we shared good food and
watched a whole lot of football we also
talked about the future of our nation as
a result of these conversations and
thoughtful consideration of the kind of
strong leadership I think American needs
I have decided to actively explore the
possibility of running for president of
the united states in january i plan to
establish a leadership PAC that will
help me facilitate conversations with
citizens across America to discuss the
most critical challenges facing our
exceptional nation packs purpose will be
to support leaders ideas and policies
that will expand opportunity and
prosperity for all Americans in the
coming months I hope to visit with many
of you and have a conversation about
restoring the promise of America best
wishes to you and your families for a
happy holiday season I'll be in touch
soon onward Jeb Bush I don't you know
this but his brother was president
two-term president his dad was a
one-term president also the director of
the sea
a way back when also a vice president
can you get that you know seeing seeing
that photo Jeb is actually holding women
down physically he's not even trying to
hide yeah so he's doing some sort of
force like a Jedi yang to push the limit
down from the glass ceiling yeah so
we've talked about this about a dirty
way but you could literally hitler for
night it could be it could be a little
bit we've talked about the bushes in the
Clintons a lot I'm not a fan of either
of them we left England because we
shouldn't be living under dynasties and
yet these people just keep coming back
and coming back and after we have Jeb
then we'll have Hillary or vice versa
then we'll have Chelsea then we'll have
Malia then we'll have who's after Malia
will get will get Sasha oh that dog the
dog will probably be President and it
all ends with Jaden Smith becoming our
president it's really um what do you
guys think just about that concept not
even about Jeb specifically but what do
you think about just this family dynasty
thing even even their mom said we've had
enough bushes in the White House
literally the dirty but uh can't seem to
get away with it but I mean from it but
um yeah I mean it really it's it's so um
incestuous uh that but almost you know
almost every you know government
politics as almost is an industry yeah
and like any you look at any industry
your father gets you in your parents get
you and your uncle gets you in you know
I have a cousin coming you know meet
this guy I mean that's how things happen
so it's more it's more human nature sort
of just like helping the people you know
and your family think it is I really do
you think it is um and then but we're
not talking about him specifically yet
well we'll get to him specifically in a
second so what do you think about the
big the big picture idea of just these
families that just it's more and more
and more regardless of what I think the
people really want it might be change
rocket racing I mean I think that it's
very sad that we've sort of accepted
political nepotism as just the way the
world you know the status quo is that
like you say someone comes along who has
name recognition we just think oh well I
remember someone like that also had a
position of leadership and therefore the
crown should should be bestowed upon he
or she
as of course with Hillary Clinton the
thing that I really worry about with
what this also means is that if these
candidates are boring and and sort of
like has Bin's or I think the toast is
done yeah there was a little holes
because Opie's bagel is done yeah
someone could get the bagels yeah um I
think that if if we continue to hear
sort of the same old same old especially
for the generations that are coming up
who are who would be interested in the
political process I think it just
doesn't do anything to excite anybody
because you know it's sort of old news
and I think that's a really dangerous
place to get stuck into and we already
have a hard time reaching voters and
people you know sort maybe I salute you
know you have to you have to put I'm
sorry but you have to put some
responsibility on the American public to
because we are we are star searchers
this is what we do we like oh we like
famous people yeah we like people that
we know we don't want to know anything
new you don't want to see the jawline on
Jeb Bush I mean that's that's a movie
star right there right I mean come on
lets you have the judge yeah he does
midheaven oh I'll online I was oh yeah
we got to say he looks more like a soft
shadow yeah sort of like it's sort of
like a feeling yeah um so to that point
so I agree with both you I think it's
terrible and then I also agree that it
is we're [ __ ] we like the name
recognition there's this idea of this
dynasty family you think you could say
[ __ ] there's yeah you'll get a couple in
okay but you know like the tailor we
think of places like the Kennedy
compound and what are the bushes have in
Kennebunkport or like we think of you
the brightest tease but really what what
could be worse for just the narrative of
the country and just the discussion and
changing things then Hillary verse Jeb
and then we'll get to the specific
design but just the idea that nothing we
had like a little eight years of a
different guy and then cuz actually i
think is gonna happen here people are
gonna go out we at eight years the other
guy we didn't really like that and now
we're gonna go right oh we need the old
guys again right i know well it's
terrible because we are so afraid we say
we want change and get we want to
venture into the unfamiliar yeah you
know in that but that is in dick
you can look at almost any area in our
society and it's like that yeah oh you
know environment cars the clothing
people where I mean look everybody how
many people you were looking at this guy
on we were looking at the sky and the
phone he you know he does somebody who
look so different it's it's like it's
like things either a freaky or we want
to be part of it you know and it is that
these foreshadowing the story was good a
will annotate back to do it we can do
fancy things here well I think that
what's really amazing about this I think
we're totally missing is like the
unbelievably close parallel to back to
the future part two where like 30 years
in the future everybody exactly by the
time person who I think who they were in
the aid right yeah and and yet we have
no hoverboard we didn't get wet you know
we do know yeah we do we do we do we
kind of joke is dated damn gets you
almost have one yeah and you know that I
think it's very sad like we said before
but also boring yeah you know let's like
have something interesting happen and
let's have something that's that's going
to maybe give us a different look into
someone who could leave the country yeah
you know I think I really think it would
behoove us to all study sociology and
CEO history really does repeat itself
and how the human condition helps to
perpetuate it and in order to get out of
this pattern you gotta take risks and on
each individual has to start taking
risks in the microcosm of his or her
life and then it can radiate out yeah
but why would anyone want to be
President I don't even think we have to
get into the specifics of Jeb I have a
feeling you don't like Jeb that much but
why would anyone want to be president at
this point when we live in this world
where all we know about hacking and all
your emails can get out and picture I
feel like we just if you want that power
at this point we're like turning a
corner here where every present disaster
is going to be at every turn like we're
gonna go into everybody's going to be
getting impeached ramallah scandal yeah
relentlessly I really think we're
turning a corner into like bizarro land
with why would you want like this family
is so powerful
the Bush family like can't they
consolidated another way that we don't
need a guy that's going to be President
to write or is it just that power is
that look at you go it's just it's ego
but I mean and the only time I've ever
felt this was and I've been a few times
but most recently with my family went to
the to the Reagan Library in Simi Valley
and I mean you know for for all that it
is maybe it's a little bit you know sort
of one-sided certainly but to go into
sort of experience like what sort of the
optimism I think that that the
projection of the Reagan legacy is and
sort of like the idea that you can sort
of really base your presidency on being
like a figurehead for for positive
feelings about the country I think that
is sort of like enticing you know if you
are looking for like an ego boost right
but I you know I think that now you know
that was a different time before we had
email we had Twitter we were it was much
easier I think to craft the narrative
than it is right by the way I know that
nothing excites the commenters more than
a positive reference of Reagan so it's a
candy rhys-meyers go to him directly on
there yeah I think that Kathie wrap us
up here well not what I was saying is
that I you know I oops i am at hard an
idealist i think and i like to think
that there was someone who wants to do
good and but in order to do good with in
a corrupt system I honestly don't know
how one goes about yes I completely
agree and I don't you know because in
order to get ahead in the political game
you have to play the political game with
it which is inherently corrupt thus we
get the same families over and over and
things don't change that much all right
let's move on speaking of things not
changing that much do you know we're in
a war in Iraq we've been in this war it
kinda ended then we started it again
then we went to Syria we didn't get
congressional authorization for that
nobody thoughts about that I talked
about it but nobody else does and now in
the city of Erbil which is about 30
miles away basically from where all this
crazy Isis stuff is happening something
really really bizarre is happening and
got a couple images that looks like a
mouse doesn't it does it looks like the
white house in general yeah it does that
looks like a Beverly Torian White House
they are literally building a replica of
the White House this is one this is one
of many many giant villas that they're
building this is literally 30 miles from
the worst of the war zone that's going
on over there but there's a lot of money
happening why are they doing it so money
brings more throw a couple of the images
back up real quick so I can give you
some more info so many of the goals are
gated and walled of course and they're
valued at over 600 grand the the replica
of the white house is worth 16 and a
half million dollars and it is to sell
yeah so they're gonna sell this they're
calling it the dream City and it's got
dubai-based oh that's right lovely it's
so hideous you know if you if you pulled
that and planted it in Beverly Hills the
cut the community would rise up and it
would be raised well they would probably
give you some better landscaping in
Beverly Hills but the reason I want to
do the stories i just think this is kind
of interesting like we see all this
horrific stuff happening there there's
no doubt that there's obviously awful
stuff Iraq basically isn't even a state
anymore um and yet somehow 30 miles from
the epicenter of all this right there's
a millionaire money be a development so
yeah it's literally right it's like an
old ozone I want to have the Swiss are
there really have good private schools
in the wall there they're really upset
about the the subway that they're going
to be puttin underneath oh man cuz then
you bring in the bed ring and all the
people from Isis yeah what do you make
it something like this really why he
creates are gonna open this somebody who
builds a mansion 30 miles away from like
the front lines of Isis is probably not
very concerned with Isis which i think
is probably the most problematic thing
about that because they there encodes
with us I don't know I mean you know you
gotta wonder like will we be offended if
someone blows this up like sort of as a
as like and kind of additional a you
know an effigy also write me was like
aren't they basically begging for that
thing to be blown up like it's just it's
like like it's taunting I think it's a
bit of taunting yeah is it sort of like
look we can do this as well you know or
maybe they're just really big fans at
Jeff Goldblum independence day they're
doing it ended well they are making it
they're doing this is actually a set
piece I never saw in the second you
never say independent it looks so stupid
to me um are you when i saw the all
right guys yeah sorry your idiot sorry
Joe mean this wow he's God re oh it was
so loudly in my microphone I'm so sorry
that's all right person you've
apologized like eight times wrong look
that's your it that's right I'm caddy be
apologizing comic Oh does anything about
Iraq or any of this stuff surprise you
guys anymore like you know you mean we
the war wrapped up then it started again
then it crossed borders then we know
buddy talked about Isis if you look at a
year ago now and you look at every CNN
piece nobody had ever even heard of Isis
so like does anything so when you see a
replica White House going up even though
I was surprised for 10 seconds then I
was like ah at this point not none of
this [ __ ] surprises me I mean it I know
we're not talking about this um today
it's not on the on the roster but with
the kiddos school kids killed mm-hmm in
Pakistan I mean what kind of a mind
decides that this is a viable action to
take yeah none of this [ __ ] surprises me
and it's horrifying I know that building
these homes is not horrifying in that
same way but it's completely it's as a
logic I know but right that's what i
mean so obviously there's no comparison
240 kids being killed in pakistan to it
but that's what i mean like there's so
much going on at once it's it's like I
can't even wrap my brain around yeah how
do you try to wrap your right your brain
around this stuff like a lot of alcohol
generally speaking you know I mean
honestly I think the best thing that you
could ever do is to turn off the news
and just not pay attention for a while
because if you do I think like probably
like we are news junkies you know if
you're if you're in it all the time it
is just constant depression I know but
what I understand that but why is it
better to like not know I don't know
that it's necessarily better to not know
from a like humanitarian standpoint but
just from like a person's like mental
stability standpoint save yourself well
if you want the if you want the answer
to Andy's point I did
deep philosophical piece on this that we
just recorded yesterday with Kelly
Carlin about how you deal with the news
and how it affects your spirit how much
you should put into it so will annotate
to that you can check that out and let's
move on you're not going to believe this
guy's but men are complete idiots that's
right science has finally proven it
there is a study from the British
Medical Journal that outlines what
they're calling the male idiot theory or
MIT not school the male idiot theory and
it basically says that men are idiots
and idiots do stupid things we've got
some more info for you authors examined
the recorded facts of about 300 people
who have been given the Darwin Award
over the last 20 years the Darwin Award
is a posthumous honor given to people
who have died through instances of
stupidity more than eighty eight percent
of Darwin Award winners were male I'm
shocked the theory is that males
engaging far more risk-taking behavior
while for females the prerogative is
geared more towards keeping oneself
alive to ensure the survival of their
offspring so I think a lot of that's
kind of just genetic and sort of
hunter-gatherer versus the woman taking
care of the home kind of stuff but now
the scientists have jumped in on this as
the female on the panel here would you
agree that men are idiots I mean come on
I had to bring this because I knew we
were talking about this job one of my
favorite it's to cave women walking
along and one says to the other they're
all Neanderthals there you go so yeah I
mean men men are idiots right like we do
stupid things that women don't do what I
when I was reading that it was just
making me think of like every idiotic
thing that I ever dating oh you know you
mean like in college you stopped after
you got most of my like sheerly idiotic
things like you know drinking from a
puddle that was on a roof that they had
like a 20 foot thing come down and then
ride a bike while I was drunker I mean
look not that there are women who do ya
wit ya but I think the percentages show
that mostly men um don't think ahead
okay you know right ready I mean I think
a study sample this is 300 of like the
dumbest people in history well how do
you know
oh lawd well I mean they've died because
they've you know they they were stupid
and I guess that you know still it's
only 300 people this is sort of like
self-selected it could also be that the
way that the stupid women died just
wasn't as interesting or wasn't as funny
because like I think there is sort of
something within the mail I don't know
if it's like like barbaric mentality is
sort of like show off how's the ganthor
but yeah I mean absolutely that but I
think also you know it's like the study
said we as men are more likely to take
risks we drive fast we commit more
crimes we take more drugs we skydive
more I mean there's a things that are
more about like like showing off essa
sara lee and i think that in a lot of
scenarios like that where risk is
involved like you're gonna put yourself
in a situation where clearly yeah are
you here supporting nigerians yeah yeah
alright alright so in that case I guess
I guess I'll have to agree with it but
that was a pretty CEO you argued both
points I was a pretty salient argument
for a man yeah thank you i know it's
amazing that i wasn't like you know off
doing something stupid you know wow
you're like sorry having yourself while
you're doing that yeah but but I mean
you know the way it's couched men are
idiots is you know that's stupid but but
I mean but I do think that men are not
in general or not as a careful of it
right now I wonder I wonder if we were
to look again this is obviously a small
reported right terrible communicators
well that we know that much horrible I
think judging by this panel alone like
that's pretty clear better so come on
that at all i'm not saying you guys but
I'm actually just talking about your
husband I yeah that was the subtext all
this i'm waiting for sale oh my previous
boyfriends all better just terrible how
much of this do you think also have to
do with age because i think there is
some age after here i was actually just
saying right before the show today to
our director that women in their 20s
seem way way more mature than man like
women are getting there's no you don't
think so i don't know maybe women are
just too smart did you ever think of it
that way well what's that planta their
men are from Mars and women are from
Venus there's maybe three Jersey
baseline of society women here just to
enjoy yeah that's the thing it's like
men wouldn't be so stupid if women we're
not as smart oh so we have to bring it
down I have to come I see any way that I
could put a level playing field okay
well i'm not sure if we proved that men
are not as smart or are idiots or what
we prove here but i'm curious to know
your thoughts so let us know in the
comment section right down below a
digital technology professor at the
ontario institute of technology has
written an interesting piece on the Elf
on the Shelf do you know about the Elf
on the Shelf if not let's take a look
see you watches a try
and make you tell send to the news is ok
ok so the Elf on the Shelf basically
sits on the shelf then is watching the
kids so that he can report back to Santa
where the kids have been naughty or nice
well Laura Pinto who is this professor
she wrote a piece on this basically
saying that that were training kids to
be accustomed to a surveillance state so
let's take a look at it a little bit of
what she wrote sure oh you're teaching
kids a bigger lesson which is that it's
okay for other people to spy on you and
you're not entitled to privacy the elf
is an external form of non-familial
surveillance if you grow up thinking
that it's cool for the elves to watch me
and report back to Santa well then it's
cool for the NSA to watch me and report
back to the government I can't believe
I'm going to say this but I sort of
agree with her sentiment we talked so
much about the NSA and the CIA and
spying and hacking and blah blah blah
are we conditioning these kids I have a
feeling and he doesn't quite agree so
Andy you're you're not with me no I'm
with you I just think the real thing
that conditions kids de living in a
surveillance state is living in a
cerveza stage it's not like this [ __ ]
alpha it's like sitting on the shelf I
mean there's a lot bigger issues like I
don't know going to school and like
being you know like I was in a place
with like 300 cameras all over you know
all the time watching you to make sure
that the over go to school North Central
High School in Indianapolis Indiana
everything why were there so what only
six yeah why we have raised well a kids
are horrible yeah that's well then i can
attest to it you know me thank God we
had surveillance because like I you know
I'm saying you were on the bullying end
of things I think oh no I'm on the
always on the opposite schedule a lily I
will say that the main villain was
family cat may or may not have been shot
with what may or may not have been a BB
gun by someone who I may or may not have
known who may or may not have lived next
to what probably would have been my high
school and pretty sure whatever you're
saying that cat that's probably still
within the statute of limitations if you
killed the cat I didn't that wasn't me
they were over someone who who was then
calling later bye-bye the cameras the
thing is it's like I I think
somewhere in that long-winded attempt at
humor yeah you are on the witness stand
right exactly you know I think that we
are conditioned because of the fact that
we are just surrounded by cameras and
surveillance all the time okay so the
bigger point is that these cameras are
everywhere actually when I was driving
here today I drove by a Google car with
the big camera out there I mean right
down I'll lassie chanukah they're
filming everybody or they're taking
pictures formats or whatever it is yet
but the idea that this is in the house
that this concept I get it's just an
it's just an idea and I know this is
just a paper and it's sort of a law it's
a philosophical debate they're not
actually putting cameras to watch and
record these kids now but what up but it
seemed to me the the greater problem
with this is that this is how you're
motivating kids to be good people
because someone is watching it right and
it's and then you get a reward because
this thing that's watching you reports
to this [ __ ] fake guy um you know I
mean it's it's just hard to believe we
have a lot of 7 year old kids about the
silly I'm so sorry yeah um but you know
I am yeah I find that more disturbing
than anything and then and then
basically that is what is um at what
drives society be good people because
we're watching you right so I think
actually you know because because it's
good to be a good person right but be it
because we're watching you not because
it's inherently or intrinsically good so
actually it sort of seems to be the
world kind of an agreement here because
there's the cat there's the there's the
real surveillance stop right it's going
on and the idea but those two things go
handed yeah but I don't know that like I
mean I think it's such a tough it's a
tough line to cross there I mean I think
this is just sort of a creepier thing so
it's easier for us to point it and say
like this is freaky yeah but I feel like
you're a little freak yeah just like
that little guy
yeah judging her yeah i'm yeah i mean
[ __ ] um i would say like i don't know i
think that we do need a little bit of
authority I shouldn't change into their
pajamas it's quick yeah it's like what
is that creepy it's like voyeuristic in
a lot of ways I beg you I mean joking
aside like I bet there are kids that
literally turn the elf around when
they're changing or something he's
probably create she's gonna be arrested
as in his his his arms will be clasped
behind his back that's a benefit so
final thought on this do you think also
between the the real stuff so the real
cameras that are everywhere in the NSA
and that stuff which we all agree on and
then the idea of this stuff do you think
kids that are growing up now with all
this do you think they'll ever revolt
against it like I think I'm part of that
last generation that had it the other
way you know you mean if you're
somewhere in your 30s maybe upper 20s
you didn't fully grow up with all this
but they really are growing up with all
this do you think they will ever i think
so i think revolt all ultimately always
happens that's what happens you boat you
build up to a boiling point there's a
revolution and there's change and then
you start building up again to another
boiling point that seems to be the way
history goes but it's like will we be to
just much enthralled in your Facebook's
girl till you do you think you think
we're just gonna you think we're on our
way to another paradigm of humanity I
think we might be i sort of i think that
ebb and flow thing and that there are
cyclical things yeah but then on the
other hand i do think that the
technology is becoming so powerful that
it's actually changing the way we are
well we're just gonna be little microbes
we're little microbes in a big matrix e
thing what do you think comment right
down below did you guys know that there
is porn on the computer there yeah there
is porn online i know i know you're
gonna have to pause this and find it for
the very first time but yeah on this
little screen that you're looking at me
right now there is porn you could
actually you probably have it open in
another tab we know what you're doing
don't think we don't as kathy goes to
her phone and sees what's what and
andy's joining her anyway so pornhub
came out with a map explaining where
people are watching porn on their
desktops where they're doing it on their
mobile devices and where they're doing
it on their consoles that's I guess
their xboxes and playstations
probably my Nintendo my 8-bit Nintendo
in 1985 did not have port tell you that
much but we did have to blow in it to
get the games to work let's take a look
at the exactly let's take a look at the
desktop version where this is where
people are looking at porn on their
desktop so the more purple pink it is
that means they're going desktop and the
more light blue it is that means that
they're not watching it that much on the
desktop so basically main so the more
blood going to the area yeah yeah
there's a good yeah there's a perfect
analogy so main people are watching it
on the desktop let's look at the mobile
map real quick so moberly people down
south they like having their porn on the
go that seems to be the only computers
that they can afford to use in the south
or at libraries yeah oh yes you're right
very bizarre and now let's look at the
people that are watching porn on their
video game system in Montana Montana
North and South Dakota yeah I will say
Indiana which you all know I've talked
about many times this is where I'm from
a race yes please explain the Indiana's
out in the middle for both desktop and
mobile and tablet which I feel like is
very appropriate yeah you guys are just
very very average however on console
there might be more people may be other
than Montana watching porn on their xbox
or playstation than in any other state
yeah then then indiana which i think is
a strange but um sort of proud moment
for me so I'm share that with
congratulations they also they should
have another map of three people
watching it at the Pussycat theatre
educators existing there's one of Holly
there is one and what's house only yeah
and I Drive by it all the time and I'm
always like who actually is going to
this place because it's called the [ __ ]
can it's probably not West Hollywood I
got is called the Pussycat cuz it used
to be they usually cosecant it's called
the studs theater is it in West
Hollywood yeah but really I always think
like who's going there because we all
have access to the whole time so without
getting into your personal yeah that's
all i'll let that slide that's it that's
another day that's another show ever um
there so i really like all of the porn
that I've probably ever do 99% of it has
been at a desktop or laptop we I the
laptop so that would be the equivalent
but so all these people they're doing it
moberly yeah what's the deal
like what are they doing are they going
again old with you're probably sitting
so I don't think they're walking down
the street watching it I mean some of
them probably are yeah I mean no but
really if you're watching it on a mobile
device like why wouldn't you watch it on
your imaginary big space so you're not
so you're you're just out and about what
if you shot your at a hotel you need
porn you're shopping shopping you need
porn you go sit down in the cafe I can't
believe is a place called pornhub I mean
actually I can't even get over things
really give me something explain these
mobile porn people to me I have no I
mean I don't know I mean apparently a
lot of people are doing it maybe it's
like the convenience factor and it's
like oh god I gotta walk all the way
over to the other side of the room log
on to the computer got my phone already
right what I think it really enjoyed
your host is like I wanted your get now
I don't have to it's my part and I need
it now yeah uh it's it makes me so
disgusted when I think about like other
people's phones now oh hot DP you know
right you're touching like like it would
hide hygiene already you know really bad
I haven't I do these sir how do they do
these well by because I think they can
see it I mean it's not verts it's not so
hard he knows we're back together well
we're back to the elf on the shelf I see
who I mean you yeah there's another
story we discovered will annotate to
that one there's something good actually
about all this that we can talk about
this stuff and it's so normalized now
like I remember when I was a kid like I
remember finding a stack of porn
magazines like a block away by the
mailbox and it was like that was my
first access to porn I was probably 10
or out of well away by the minute like
somebody like know somebody like next to
a tree years well you know how they say
when people are about to kill themselves
they give away all their stuff so I feel
like it was a guy that is that the
killers of anyone to get rid of all was
born so you just left it there the next
suicide the next generation I don't know
I'm making that part up but my left but
my point is that there was such a stigma
to porn and now we can all talk about it
was great everyone knows it's out there
and I um first of all not into porn at
all okay not not one bit doesn't do a
thing for me fight Lee disgusts me um
but I remember when I was about ten I
went it up to the my father had a stack
of playboy mag
high up in the closet and I went up
there and we had some friends over
family friends over and they the
grown-ups were in the other room and my
friend and i found these classic
playboys carroll baker marilyn monroe
etc Jayne Mansfield and we're flipping
through it and my father came in and we
were so busted but that was that was the
height of it yeah that was that we're
talking about the 1960s that was the
height of it then right so that's likely
magazine women like lounging on red
satin right right and it's a little more
graphic now I know you're not making it
to the point what's being I've seen some
of it yeah but isn't that like so to me
that seems like a net good the P because
people always liked porn people are
always watching more but it was never
talked about now it's sort of like
everyone knows it's out there is all
right we've removed some of the stigma
of something that's totally natural
watching people [ __ ] so much I'm 26 yeah
I think the last time we'll go with that
Bob and so I kind of grew up in the era
of the internet porn yeah was always all
right so i don't really know that i have
it to compare it to anything else but I
know as a kid or as a younger person
like it was definitely terrifying think
like oh my god like what if it somebody
gonna catch me you know sorry so so that
time new thing is still there when
you're younger and maybe we've
accelerated it because first of all
there's just way more graphic like oh my
god like a riffic [ __ ] right um and and
I see what I know that that is done is
like that's cute people sort of
expectations for like what sex is and
like what what yeah yeah should be
that's a whole other find it erotic I
mean I like watching the show like the
affair that's what that does it for me
but analogous I don't know if you're
yeah that's a bad thing no no that's big
that's great I check all right you know
what you know what I always say about
poor into e cheese hole did you cheek to
each his hole did you say fast about it
I already finally got the joke a new
study has come out confirming what I
certainly know which is that having a
pet can actually make you healthier
we've got some info for you this from
the Washington Post the human animal
bond research initiative foundation that
is a lot of words they recently found
evidence that human animal interactions
could lift mood
do stress and anxiety perhaps by
activating the hormone oxytocin now as a
dog lover I've talked about a lot my dog
has brought a tremendous amount of joy
to my life I see this all the time with
people that love animals and adopt
animals and I am not surprised by any of
this so sometimes it's nice when when
science confirms some [ __ ] that you know
I thought that was I thought that had
been confirmed but but they're double
confirm Agathe isn't just going back
there they're updating your confirmation
but they need time to do my dog saved my
life all day every day I mean literally
they saved my life Justin keeping your
spirits up in the area giving me that
the love that no other creature gives me
accepting the love in a way that no
other creature accepts it well it's just
that it's that unconditional part of my
day I mean I just love it and I think
it's terrible for my daughter husband
his there's no there's no strife if my
dog is looking at me and thinking I'm an
[ __ ] he doesn't say it so I can't you
know there's no there's no conf oh yeah
well I always think it's funny when
people talk about like having kids and
they're always like yeah well you know
it's a lot of work and your life changes
and that and not to say it's not
rewarding but there's always that they
would start with that yeah yeah but when
someone has a dog or you need to move it
oh my god this is the best time this dog
chewed my love enjoy their correct me
wrong I think you might be a cat guy oh
yeah absolutely you are you know sick
twisted you know I think a long time ago
I made a comment about like setting a
cat on fire and that's like the number
one thing that I still get like hate
about on Twitter so you don't have ki
never actually set a count on fire for
the record and I would have never done
that I don't hate cats it's just funny
to hate cats so like I go for that so
you don't have a cat I don't have a pen
no I'm not a cat person at all my god I
love dogs you're kidding me yeah I just
told a story about shooting a cat with a
BB gun earlier oh that was earlier
little out of date back to that yeah you
have to um I have dogs and I love dogs
and it totally makes perfect sense and I
think any place where you have a work
situation where you can bring in your
dog i think it just increases overall
productivity of course that's not
scientific that I know of I bet you
there maybe it does but but I just think
that it's such a nice
thank god i wish i had my phone then i
would show you my little boys yeah so
alright so we're all we're all agreed on
the dog thing but now let's talk about
cats for a second because every time I
do let's talk about cakes could give you
the overnight eat all your major thanks
no but really let's talk about cats for
a second because I don't like cats I'm
allergic to cats I've had family members
with tats that have tried to attack me
my dog and a cat got into a big fight
once my dog left bleeding so I don't
know I don't like cats but I know people
love cat right so I don't want to just
attack the community now even though
they're all nuts we all know that right
captain fire days the internet running
on the section i don't know i know look
I have I know people that I love and
respect who have these sweet cats and
I'm just not attracted to them yeah the
big problem I have with cats is that
they'll be really nice and doing it and
then they pounce it's like there's like
no reason like you there's no trust
right and she look at people the cat
people always say well because you dog
people there's a you dog people it's
because you're so needy and you need
that affection constantly I'm a cat
person I'm self-aware and I just want an
animal that stairs and judges me all the
time I guess it's something like that I
don't although they've also proven the
cat feces like releases some toxin that
makes people crazy right explains the
collie Catwoman yes stay okay I tribes
trying to be nice to the cat people to
wrap us up with you I mean I think
you've pretty much said it all cat
people are weird you know no I'll give
but I know somebody who was like 16 cats
she loves them yeah certainly she
doesn't get out my station oh she does
she gets out a lot but she and Jules has
two dogs to dog those poor dogs anyway
cat people you know I'm trying I'm
trying here tell us why you love cats I
want to know and dog people I know why
you love your dog so you but feel free
to comment right Emma according to the
Washington Post Americans are not
getting enough sleep and it is literally
killing us let's take a look so this is
what people are doing instead of getting
enough sleep these this is for sleepers
that get less than six hours per night
and I always heard that you're supposed
to get eight hours I try to get
somewhere around eight hours normal
sleepers get 6 to 11 but this is people
that get less than six they're working
that certainly doesn't surprise writing
they're commuting they're socializing
tossing and turning I mean a lot of
people definitely of that but
why ever save time for that but that's
why everyone's on ambien these days
they're grooming health related things
relaxing playing games watching TV so
not all these things are stress related
but you know your body does actually go
through processes when you're sleeping
that it needs to get ready for the next
day and sleep is important do you guys
do you feel you get enough sleep
absolutely not oh god I get last night I
had such a bad day yesterday like one of
the worst days from morning till night I
actually went to bed at ten thirty which
is I haven't I can't even remember when
I've gone to bed that early but normally
I get maybe six and a half hours and
it's nowhere near enough and I walk
around exhausted yeah are you tired
right now you seem very alert in the way
or not I feel are you highly caffeinated
not at all really so there had one cup
of coffee do I seem highly caffeinated
no but if you're not getting enough
sleep you're nobody good night sleep
last night but I know that one night
doesn't make a difference don't you
actually get a sleep deficit yeah I
definitely need a lot more sleep and I
don't get deep enough sleep and it's def
it's debilitating and it's depressing
yeah it really is debilitating a
depressing ah yeah you know I think an
interesting thing about this chart is
that like the people were only working
instead of sleeping because that's the
only thing that no one else is making
you do out of all those other things
Ryan I mean you know you can you can
turn turn down you know socializing or
playing games or commuting I guess well
maybe not commuting but like can't
really with working yeah but I think
like I just uh I just wrapped a show or
just wrapped production on a show called
America cooks with chefs you should
check it out an aura TV good plug and
like last night you know we're airing
episodes right now is the last night of
course we were in edit until you know
two in the morning and then going
driving home and I'm back for this you
know it's like I think especially in an
era now where like we're so
interconnected and we're expected to be
available all the time 24-7 it's very
hard to like stop working and to stop
doing yeah things that we you would
normally not do instead of sleeping yeah
so all right so I want to get to that so
I'll skip ahead a little bit so that
thing that we never stop right how do
you manage that in your alive been
asking every guest now for weeks because
I think everybody's struggling with this
thing you know I realized for a while
that I was starting in the morning at my
phone before I got out of bed and then
I'm looking at it before I went to sleep
and then
really you're just putting yourself in
this world costly so I've stopped I've
actually stopped doing that but how do
you manage that because that's what it
is work even yeah no it's not work
technically often if you're just on
social media it's still just this
endless thing it's always been a big
challenge for me and and I come from a
family like that my sister I always talk
about it's like it's like we're physics
experiments and it is a leaf you are
yellow it fills it yeah and it's like
it's so hard for me I actually sometimes
have to block out time to not do
anything yeah and it's very hard for me
to say no when you know we live in a
very competitive society and if I feel
if I don't if I don't keep doing doing
and throwing more [ __ ] against the wall
and it's and it's a fallacy it's a bad
philosophy yeah and sleeping it's not
I'm deeply all i'm doing is depleting
yeah i'm not nourishing i'm here at
least on a multivitamin um on your honor
my bed okay my last one on this do you
think Americans need a siesta you know
many Western European nations have a
siesta I'll do it every now and again
like on a random weekday like it like
four o'clock I just like literally I'll
take like a even if it's a 15 minute
power nap and then I feel great for the
rest of the day now it's against
everything that seemed consumerism and
capitalism really seems to be about like
we can't stop yeah I don't believe the
confirmation for Spieler do it but do
Americans need that concept at least
that idea that you can shut down for a
little bit in the day well I would if we
were working in factories like I think
we were a hundred years ago probably
more primarily speaking like I think it
would be a different conversation but I
think a lot of studies have come out
recently they said you know people don't
really even function that well more than
four or five hours at a time you know
doing one specific task right so you
know maybe maybe we need to change that
maybe people be more productive if they
felt like they didn't have to always be
just sitting at even desk waiting for
the Gator on it's interesting even the
way you answer that though that people
would be more productive like that right
that Matt Hagan goes you know it why
can't people have a better quality of
life Joe and I think that it would lead
to that though yeah I think you'd have a
better quality of life
it's what is this place sorry yes oh no
I'm just I'm just knowing I know what
you mean let me let me clarify that than
by saying that I think that you know as
if you're a business owner and you say
like I want people to be productive but
if I give them a better quality of life
by not expecting them to just sit at a
desk and run out of clock maybe in turn
that I actually would be better for
everybody involved in like you'd have a
power having babies and your business
would be well you know we can end this
with a bit of good news particularly for
you because we did a story a couple
months ago that your employer Carlos
Slim who I think is the second richest
man in the entire world and who owns or
a TV that aunty works that he he was
advocating for a really short work week
yeah he wants to cut the days and cut
the hours that's cuz he doesn't want to
pay you don't get to be the second
richest guy in the world by paying
overtime I'll tell you that to shade no
he's great he's wonderful I don't mean
any of that if you don't think we got
enough lists during the year in this
BuzzFeed world that we live in well the
years about end and that's where we
really double down on the list so we've
got a list of the most googled terms in
2014 all right so we're gonna we're
gonna hit a couple of these so Robin
Williams was the most googled term in
2014 so what surprised me about that
just real quick is that you know that
was just an instance that have you know
it happened one day obviously and then
it it was the burst for a week a shock
but it wasn't something that was going
on all year so I thought that even
though it was shocking of course that
the net sort of usage of that term I'm
surprised that was an important thing a
World Cup number two that was obviously
huge for you know the two months or so
that it was going on Ebola the Malaysia
Airlines I want to talk a bit more about
that the ALS ice bucket challenge flappy
bird I know now in flappy bird is a nap
i didn't even download it i fought the
power I'd never have played blackberry
and I fought harder than you do conchita
wurst which we did a little research on
will tell you about that in a second
Isis obviously it's no surprise frozen
was one of the big movies of the year
and the socially so these were the top
ten most search terms I have to
apologize again yeah I keep clearing my
throat because I have such bad post
nasal drip so I'm really sorry that was
like that was actually number 11 was
post nasal drip
let number 11 you know when you put
Kathy ladnun into google yeah it was
kind of post-nasal drip completely comes
up about that I can't follow him so is
there anything on that list or me that
surprised you in any way it seemed it
basically sort of [ __ ] somewhat yeah
Robin Williams is the number one terms
is surprising absolutely and sad yeah
and I think that if you do look at all
of the things that are sort of in the
top 10 list it is a really good snapshot
of sort of what we thought about what we
were really pre-conceived that's that's
right where we were we were host
considerably or we were preoccupied with
ya during the year last year I'm curious
the other thing about what your guys's
top Google searches was for me it was of
course and eerie spire because whatever
saying how many times would you repeat
Google anything other than yourself
right so I don't know how you know
usually my googling involved well my my
partner my fiancé now I could say he
cooks a lot so a lot of times you yell
things at a kitchen a measurement thing
so I google measurements all right
that's my that's my break or just not
you know a little factoid yeah I don't
think I think I google constantly and I
love it and I can't believe that it
hasn't been around my whole life but I
don't think there's anything that I
google predominantly do you guys think
that there's less stuff in your brains
now because of this like you don't have
to store yeah you don't have to keep
information i remember when i was a kid
like playing Trivial Pursuit with my
family and my uncles especially my uncle
and my dad were so amazing it remember
every little fact about World War two
and the day that this happened and that
happened and I feel like nobody of the
next generation probably starting with
Gen X mm-hmm don't remember things in
that way because we can just go to the
well let's see bound back to my head
back to me being like a physics
experiment that doesn't mentioned last
time but the things that I don't need to
keep in my brain Gareth I get rid of
phone numbers don't remember those much
anymore yeah um but it gets filled with
other stuff my friend used to have it
have a theory that your brain is like a
bucket and you can only fit as much into
it as you can yeah and if you leave room
in the bucket then more stuff will come
into it so so I don't remember certain
things that are so easily accessible
yeah I have a good friend who's a
which is most exciting yeah occupations
said we always joke that my brain is
like a warehouse but like a bomb went
off and there's a ton of stuff but it
takes a while to get to and his brain is
like a really small organized closet you
can it's not a lot in there but you can
get to a pretty high so yeah great guy
great guy does you have to have to have
to be sort of like labels that you like
why you can't remember a person's name
you have to kind of develop a system
like this person I remember his name is
Bill because he has that baseball cap or
some size you know something and I don't
do that enough demonic like you're right
thank you but there are certain people
that whose names i just cannot so what
so the Robin Williams thing yeah what I
think that's particularly interesting as
I said is that because it just it was
this burst and that it still became the
number one so what does that say about
us like when we all share this like in
this case a pretty horrific thing what
does that phenomena yeah I don't know
well I mean I think what you're saying
is absolutely correct though it's like
and I did a couple of papers about this
back in college where the ability to
access a lot of different things all at
once sort of has created a divergent
pattern for like our cultural
experiences so it's like because there
are so many different kinds of artists
that you can listen to from a music
perspective like you don't have to have
a room where everybody knows who what
you know what's going on so when these
moments happen these mash finale style
moments yeah you know we're like
everybody goes to the bathroom of the
commercial break so like the water table
lowers right because they're also
involved in the show those kinds of
things when they happen well it's
unfortunate that you know he passed away
of course it's it is sort of special
that like all of us for like a moment
are to sort of even if we are googling
doing the same thing it's like it's like
because we're all we were in such an
isolated society that we all kind of
converged like this in a very yeah
modern way yeah but I also think that
what what that says is that you know to
a lot of people Robin Williams was an
incredible source of joy yeah and for
him to die in that way Ren was so rocked
so many people's worlds i think that's
interesting so you think maybe even if
he had died in another way let's say it
had just been a car accident that it
wouldn't have got the traction so it
really I feel
he to you know to people who don't get
the personality of the comic yeah which
is a lot of people the fact that he took
his own life and and and was suffered
from depression we are heated other two
people he was he was like a savior he
was like he was delighted he didn't have
the light yeah I think that was a really
tragic moment for people absolutely
alright so the last one that I want to
touch on real quick the Malaysian plane
yeah we everyone talked about it for
that month CNN did like two months of
wall to wall endless speculation which
was always preface by saying we're not
going to speculate what happened and
then they'd speculate for two hours we
never found the plane which i think is
kind of interesting so they force this
stuff down our throats it's who the hell
knows what happened it's a pretty sick
story actually if you if you really
think about it that we never found this
plane but so we were forced fed it by
the media for that amount of time it
never resolved itself and now we never
talked about right right so what does
that say about we how we use jazz on to
the next thing that's being forced down
our throats you've watched CNN for the
past four weeks it's all been protesting
but police violence police violence like
yeah non-stop they'll do a breaking news
alert at the top of every hour and it'll
be literally the exact same thing over
and over and over again and i think that
you know cnn's model and especially like
with all the other sort of local or not
local but national news organizations to
sort of like just think that like they
can get behind a thing that's just gonna
get up traction and just push it until
it's dead dead dead been dead might work
for casual viewers for people like us
you know who watch a lot maybe it's
right yeah that's really horrible and on
that note that's why i did doing this on
the internet because if you don't like a
topic you just look at it you don't have
to click it i'll shopping you go shot
baby rock I learn whatever else very
much but hopefully you at least click an
immediate on your car maybe watch the
Edit maybe not in the console don't
watch the porn on the console anyway I
want to thank Kathy and Andy their
twitterers are right down below if you
have any suggestions how Kathy can do
with her hostname which there's a drip
leave or if you want to talk to Andy
about his feelings about cats please do
follow them right there and thank you
very much you will do it again next week